EUGENE FITZGERALD: What do
you think innovation is?
ANDREAS WANKERL: Innovation is the
process of putting ideas into useful
form and bringing them to market.
EUGENE FITZGERALD: When you think about
innovation you might be thinking
of the smartphone, or Facebook, or
eBay, or iTunes, or Pandora.
ANDREAS WANKERL: However, these are
incremental innovations, built upon
earlier, more fundamental innovations.
EUGENE FITZGERALD: Like transistors,
[? sub-ejector ?]
lasers, or integrated circuits.
In the past, pipelines existed
to help innovators.
Innovation took years to development,
and created growth for decades.
However, these pipelines
no longer exist.
ANDREAS WANKERL: We are in a worldwide
innovation crisis.
This crisis has impacted everyone
and everything.
And it has stunted worldwide
economic growth.
Something needs to be done.
EUGENE FITZGERALD: A new paradigm
shift is necessary.
We'll teach you how to think about
innovation, about the processes and
the language involved.
ANDREAS WANKERL: It's time to get back
to business, the business of
innovating.
So roll up your sleeves
and jump into 3.086x.
EUGENE FITZGERALD: Become
part of the solution.